lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es
explorar las figuras en dos dimensiones
que podemos construir al tomar rebanadas
planas de un cubo de que estoy hablando
supongamos que deseo construir un
cuadrado cómo puedo rebanar este cubo
con un plano para que al final de
cuentas la intersección resulte en un
cuadrado bien imaginemos que el plano va
a cortar al cubo de esta manera el
cuadrado es la figura más obvia así es
que el plano corte el cubo en la parte
de arriba aquí corta esta cara por aquí
este es el corte en esta cara la cara
posterior le está cortando por aquí es
esta línea punteada en un cubo de
cristal lo podríamos ver mientras que la
base le estaría cortando por aquí ya te
puedes imaginar el plano que hizo esto
de hecho vamos a dibujar lo voy a
dibujar una perspectiva más amplia del
plano que ha hecho este corte déjame ver
si puedo dibujar un plano decente aquí
esta sería de hecho una parte del plano
que está cortando este cubo y se vería
más o menos más o menos así mejor aún
aquí puedo sombrear la parte del plano
que tú puedes ver suponiendo que el cubo
tiene una superficie opaca es decir no
se puede ver a través de él lo que
estarías viendo entonces es esta línea
punteada y así es como se vería el plano
así es que obtener un cuadrado al
rebanar un cubo con un plano es algo
relativamente fácil de realizar pero qué
hay de un rectángulo cómo le hacemos
para obtener un rectángulo aquí te
invito para que en cualquier momento le
pongas pausa al vídeo y trates de ver
cómo puedes obtener estas figuras por ti
mismo para un rectángulo puedes cortar
así si cortas esta cara por aquí de esta
manera cortas esta cara así y luego
cortas esta cara por aquí creo que ya te
diste cuenta cómo va esto esta cara la
cortamos entonces así por lo que la base
es cortada de esta manera así es que la
intersección del cubo con el plano con
el cual lo estamos cortando por aquí
tendríamos entonces
con el cual estamos cortando el cubo así
es que la intersección de este plano con
el cual estoy cortando el cubo va a ser
un rectángulo se vería más o menos así y
de nueva cuenta déjame sombrear esto si
así es como vemos esto y aquí podríamos
imaginarnos que este plano es como esas
navajas enormes que usan los magos para
partir a las personas a la mitad o más
bien darnos la ilusión de que están
partiendo a las personas en dos se vería
más o menos así y esto no parece tan
difícil aquí la intersección del plano
con el cubo es un cuadrado mientras que
aquí es un rectángulo pero que con un
triángulo nuevamente te invito a que le
pongas pausa el vídeo e intentes
encontrarlo por tu cuenta un triángulo
no es tan difícil puedes cortar por aquí
esta cara aquí cortamos por acá esta
cara y finalmente destacará la cortamos
por aquí y ahí tenemos el triángulo por
supuesto aquí también podría dibujar el
plano pero creo que ya tienes la idea
aquí tenemos un tipo de triángulo pero
hay
diversos tipos de triángulos que
podríamos construir el triángulo base de
equilátero si este corte de aquí o la
longitud de este corte de aquí es igual
a la longitud de este corte de aquí y es
la misma que la longitud de este corte
en esta cara en este caso tendríamos un
triángulo equilátero si movemos este
punto hacia acá déjame hacerlo con otro
color al mover ese punto vamos a tener
un triángulo isósceles así la
intersección sería un triángulo
isósceles si movemos este punto lo más
cerca posible a este vértice tendríamos
casi un triángulo rectángulo aunque no
sería exactamente este ángulo de 90
grados
te estás aproximando a un ángulo recto
pero sin llegar a ser exactamente un
ángulo de 90 grados de tal manera que el
ángulo tampoco puede ser mayor de 90
grados con lo cual no podemos obtener
triángulos obtusos pero sí podríamos
obtener triángulos equiláteros
triángulos isósceles en general podemos
obtener cualquier clase de triángulo
agudo pero ahora hagamos algo realmente
interesante podemos obtener un
al rebanar un cubo con un plano y aquí
sí me gustaría que le pusieras pausa al
vídeo y pienses que se la parte
divertida cómo obtener un pentágono
cuando rebanó un cubo con un plano bien
vamos por él así es cómo vas a obtener
un pentágono al rebanar un cubo con un
plano vamos a rebanar esta cara superior
déjame hacerlo un poco diferente
entonces imaginemos que la cara superior
la rebana moss así ahora imagina que
rebana mos esta cara posterior de esta
manera esta otra cara posterior que
tampoco puedes ver la rebana moza si
ahora vamos a rebanar esta cara que
tenemos aquí así de esta manera y
finalmente esta cara la rebana moss así
y aquí es donde vendría el plano quizá
no va a ser tan obvio dibujar este plano
pero ya tienes la idea general si rebanó
aquí en ángulo recto bueno no no
precisamente haciendo un ángulo recto
más bien no debería haber mencionado eso
el ángulo
para no confundir te sí rebanó en los
ángulos adecuados
entonces la intersección del plano con
el cubo como puedes ver aquí va a ser un
pentágono ahora sumamos la barra un poco
más alto que hay ahora de un hexágono
como se puede formar un hexágono al
rebanar con un plano bidimensional el
cubo como te puedes imaginar no te
hubiera hecho la pregunta a menos que yo
sepa cómo hacerlo veamos entonces cómo
lo hacemos si rebajamos por aquí esta
cara superior ahora rebanando la base
del cubo por aquí esta cara posterior la
vamos a rebanar de esta manera mientras
que esta otra cara posterior la vamos a
rebanar de manera similar esta cara que
podemos ver la vamos a rebanar así y
esta otra cara que también podemos ver
se rebana aquí este corte lo podía haber
hecho un poco más recto en fin espero
que hayas captado la idea de cómo
rebanar un cubo para obtener un hexágono
espero que esto te haya permitido
apreciar todo lo que podemos hacer con
un cubo sobre todo si te decides a
rebanar lo con un gran plano o rebanar
lo imaginando que tenemos lo que podría
ser un gran cuchillo que es plano espero
que hayas apreciado que hay mucho más en
un cubo de lo que podrías haber
imaginado una manera de pensar esto es
que hay seis caras en un cubo es decir
seis superficies que podrían cortarse
cuando se intersectan con un plano y
cada una de esas intersecciones forma el
lado de un polígono aquí estamos
cortando en cuatro lados aquí cortamos
también cuatro superficies formando
cuatro lados aquí cortamos en tres aquí
cortamos en cinco si te fijas no
cortamos la base del cubo y aquí
cortamos todas las caras las seis
superficies las seis caras que
constituyen el cubo